en los cielos de las grandes ciudades se
ve la lo gris de la polución la
contaminación atmosférica causada por
las actividades humanas es cada vez más
perjudicial para la salud según un
estudio publicado en la revista the
lancet planetary health las muertes
relacionadas a la contaminación del aire
aumentaron un 7% entre 2015 y 2019 un
fenómeno que causa la muerte de 9
millones de personas al año y que sigue
estando poco identificado según los
autores del estudio
la contaminación es un factor de riesgo
de muerte como muchos otros cuando se
observa que contribuye a la
contaminación se trata principalmente de
enfermedades no transmisibles que
figuran como causa real de muerte en el
certificado de funciones casi nunca
verás la contaminación como causa de
muerte
según el estudio el 75% de estas muertes
están causadas directamente por la
contaminación atmosférica pero las
muertes por exposición a sustancias
químicas y metales pesados también han
aumentado un 66 por ciento desde el año
de un fenómeno que afecta principalmente
a los países pobres y en desarrollo
cuando estos países industrializados se
produce también un fenómeno de
urbanización cada vez más personas se
trasladan a las zonas donde hay
contaminación y al mismo tiempo hay un
envejecimiento de la población y todas
estas cosas se combinan y aumentan la
carga de estas poblaciones
chad la república centroafricana y
nigeria son algunos de los países que
registran la mayor tasa de mortalidad
por la contaminación atmosférica